Aaron is with us in Nebraska hi Aaron
how are you I'm doing very well Dave
good to talk to you you too how can I
help so brief just background on me I'm
21 years old
I am completely debt-free I make about
55 to 65 thousand a year between a
couple small businesses that I owned I
have my emergency fund and where this is
going is with one of my businesses I
have about a hundred thousand dollars in
exotic snake that we breed and so on so
forth and I got a couple of buddies that
are headed to Indonesia to visit the
island where these animals come from and
these islands have never been documented
no one's been there except for local
tribes and so on and so forth and so the
only way I would be able to go with the
guys because one guys videoing it and
one guy is the guide is if I was going
to be a trip sponsor and it would cost
me about $15,000 to do why would it cost
you $15,000 to visit this island of
undocumented snakes so the trips for me
to about two to three weeks long one of
the guys that going has been in
Indonesia seven times and so what he is
is he's a guy so that's his contribution
to the trip the other person does
YouTube professionally and he's going to
be doing all the photos and videos and
so on and so forth so they're trying to
keep the headcount as low as they can
because this is honestly not a very so
it's an awesome 15,000 to go to no it
would cost about four to five grand per
person and so they don't really want to
I know these guys personally but they
don't really want to let anybody else
tag along unless they're really going to
contribute something towards the
expedition I think your buddies are
scamming you they're paying four grand
and they want you to pay fifteen to go
on a trip with them
well what one part of it bill would be
it would be the sponsor so with our
reptile business our name would be the
sponsor yeah yeah Dee Dumpty who's gonna
see it undocumented snakes
no I know if you want to go on a trip no
yeah I mean I don't blame you for going
on the trip if you want to spend four
grand you can do that if you want to
sell $15,000 worth $100,000 and snakes
in order to go that's okay too as long
as you pay cash for this but I just
don't think you're getting a good deal
here I don't think your buddies are
being buddies at all yep
I mean you pay your part they pay their
part you tag along and I'll be the I'll
be your Sherpa carry your stuff or
something maybe you pay my way and I'll
work for you while I'm there yeah maybe
I'm road crew I think they just saw an
opportunity to get some money out of you
I don't know you do whatever you want to
do I just smell them I smell a rat
there's probably not good in a bunch of
snakes but I do smell a rat um so I mean
you do whatever you want to do I doesn't
it doesn't feel right to me
from a perspective of I don't think
you're getting 15,000 I'm almost
positive you're not getting $15,000 in
value out of your sponsorship I think
that's all just BS because they just
were trying to get some money from you
but the I mean you guys all have a
common interest they want to go you want
to go hey I'll pay my part and and if
you need to give me a name because it's
Indonesia if I have to have a title you
can give me the title of sponsor but I'm
not paying for X what you guys are
paying to go so you get a free trip out
of it because you happen to know me and
talk me into this I just know I don't
like wouldn't do it you do whatever you
want to do man but pay cash for it above
your emergency fund don't go in debt
sell enough inventory to make it happen
if you're gonna do it but I don't think
you're getting $15,000 for the value and
I think you need to rethink how they're
pitching this to you I think they're
kind of walking away from these
conversations snickering I could be
wrong